what what i love about gantz and uh
terraformers it's just it's pure bat
[ __ ] insane fun oh yeah it is and like
it's it's kind of like the edgy 16 year
old in you but like there's everybody
brings out the 16 year old in you thinks
like just fighting and death is badass
but like there's there's like two like
kind of different categories i put this
in you know there's there's like the
edgy 16 year old kind of shows where it
brings that out of you and it remembers
what you felt like when you were 16 and
then the shows like elf and lead and
mirai nikki
elephant yeah that you watched and i'm
just like damn why the [ __ ] did i ever
enjoy this
yeah i can look back and i'm like that
was good yeah that was happening to look
back i'm like why was this even remotely
popular
this easy to trick when i was 16 when i
saw blood when you were 16 this is this
is new to you like yeah this [ __ ] is
exciting you're like whoa
i can do this yeah oh
it's artistic yeah it's just like yeah
it's it's it's crazy yeah i remember a
point when elephant lead was literally
when i joined the community elfin leed
was considered like a modern day classic
yeah
i think for a lot of people it still is
like i think
yeah and then and then someone was like
if you thought the anime was good read
the manga because it's like completely
different and i was like all right that
is no different no it is it is very it's
actually more [ __ ] in the manga
but like you know 16-year-old ajme was
like how how could they improve on this
and then you read it now and i'm like
all right yeah i mean i think i've like
watched like fullmetal alchemist before
it you know yeah yeah yeah i'm just
going from that where i was like okay
you went for a full middle account
yeah i was like looking at my monitor on
like all like with all these [ __ ]
pop-ups everywhere like whoa what the
[ __ ] she just cut them up yeah yeah with
like ghost arms like what
yeah from i think that like the next
show
after elfin lead and miranda was
probably a carmichael kill
where
um where i remember he got so [ __ ]
popular and i'm just like i watched the
anime okay that is what i am 16 yeah
i i am 16 like i'm 14 and this is deep
yeah i am convinced right okay i like
healthy i know evelyn i like how can i
get killed i'm gonna say it right now i
like it okay i don't care what people
say okay i like it [ __ ] you i like that
wait did you finish it the anime yeah
yeah
okay
i think this will make sense okay this
is how i view it sure
pov you're a fairy tale fan
you're tired of fairy tale you want
something a little edgier you go
immediately to act make a kill yeah
that's it feels think about it yeah it
is literally
fairy tale with but fans but with way
more edge because it feels like fairy
tale in many aspects where it's like
this is dumb dumb [ __ ] why specifically
are fairytale fans you are right you're
all right it is literally uh if you are
a fairytale fan i bet you love i can
make a kill yeah you are right hundred
percent think about it think about it
no
we need to make a chart of like what
you're likely to like based on which
show we just get like a cork board yeah
we do right i think i think if if seven
deadly sin is on one end it's like yeah
hunter hunter is on the other end i
think yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
what other shootings are there like i
don't know just like i don't know
[ __ ] seven deadly sins somewhere to
me i can't make a kill is just like the
generation they go into seven deadly
sins or fairy tale and then they also
watch mirai nikki and they were like
what if we just combine the two what if
we just combine the two and that and
then you get a calm and go kill when
you're like great i you you require even
less brain cells to enjoy this brilliant
i i even though i recognized the ending
was [ __ ] dumb for mega kill i liked
it i thought it was fun i had a great
time watching that i'm i'm not afraid to
admit this the the the plot twist yeah i
was just like calm the [ __ ] on yeah it
was come the [ __ ] off but i still had a
lot of fun like before that i had a lot
of fun with the show i really enjoyed it
yeah admittedly as much as i climbed on
archima kill first like five six
episodes pretty fun yeah it's just like
brainless fun but you know what else i
read i read all of as well was
remembered now sorry would you have
anything else no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no i'm just going to say
i read all dead man wonderland oh really
yeah oh that's also i'm succeeded yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is just sure because
oh russian back now i i wanted you know
what i went on the thing where i was
like the anime ending sucked yeah i was
like i want it i had this uh this is
like two years ago i read it i had the
feeling i was like you know what i just
want to finish and manga to an anime
that didn't get an ending announcement
yeah okay wonderland yeah and the manga
was definitely better but the manga had
a [ __ ] ending too yeah i mean not as bad
as the anime but it's still not yeah
yeah it was still [ __ ] it was fine that
my wonderland was very five hours yeah i
think i was exactly the same because i i
finished dead man wonderland and i liked
the anime a lot yeah the anime was great
until about episode 10. yeah and then
there's the last couple of episodes
whether it's like oh ran out of budget
yeah yeah basically and so i was like
okay okay i need to see how this is